what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so I feel like superwoman rebirth is one
of these stories that just kind of fell
through the cracks of BC rebirth and it
kind of makes sense to a degree I mean I
love what's going on a superwoman
rebirth right now but it kind of makes
sense right I mean the superwoman was
never like a character that was on par
with Superman I mean Supergirl was
because Supergirl was such a common
character especially during crisis on
Infinite Earths now post crisis you know
when it was the whole weird creature
from another universe because Superman
was supposed to be the last surviving
Kryptonian that was weird that was
strange the new 52 didn't quite know
what to do with with Supergirl so it was
kind of a funny situation but she's got
a legacy that stood the test upon
superwoman was never really that way she
was just kind of like this on again off
again character that DC would introduce
periodically whenever people seem to be
getting bored of Supergirl and that was
about it
but superwoman is amazing in DC rebirth
Sybil was the best thing come out of DC
rebirth right now the reason why is
because this gives us like the other
side of the coin and the cool thing is
that the weight of stories written you
know the way it really comes to us by by
Phil Phil Jimenez Phil Jimenez I'm not
really sure how you pronounce his last
name but it's kind of an interesting
idea because remember all this comes out
of the death of the new 52 Superman that
was that was a great big huge deal we'll
cover a Superman Lois and Clark will
cover that relatively soon but that was
a huge deal right you know DC sat down
and it said okay fine fans don't really
seem to be interested in the new 52
Superman he's a guy that we just can't
mess with we can mess with Batman we can
mess with Green Lantern we can mess with
Aquaman one room in the whole nine yards
but we cannot change Superman he is a
guy that will stand the test of time
he's a generational character it's the
one guy that you just can't quite reboot
and take away from the hero that he used
to be and so that's what we got you know
we got dan Jergens right super writing
Superman Lois Lee Clark which explains
how the pre new 52 Superman ended up in
the new 52 universe and so what they
started doing what do you see sort of
doing was winding everything down we got
Superman truth you know we got the the
events that led up to Superman truth you
know to hold Ulysses thing where
Superman got that new power and then it
was basically burning out as
to the point that he essentially just
died and so what this does is it
basically answers the question what
happened after the new 52 ship man died
what what happened was it just well he's
dead now and that's it or was there were
there aftershocks was there an aftermath
to his death so the cool thing about
this is that these superwoman it really
super than just kind of showing up is
just there one day and no one really
knows anything about her is just
suddenly they're superwoman now and it's
kind of interesting because everybody's
responding to or differently of course
what this does it looks like it picks up
around or after the events of Action
Comics rebirth number one I guess
actually comics rebirth the path of
Doom's we've already had the pre new 52
Superman fighting to return but the old
doomsday you know we have those we
already had that huge conflict and so as
people just kind of looking at these
events as they're unfolding with one
another and it's kind of cool because
what the super woman's been doing is
basically establishing herself as a
superhero you even have John Henry irons
you have steel you know one of the four
Superman that came out after the death
of the original Superman
you know what during the whole reign of
the Superman story arts by the way John
Henry irons was the character the DC
just never really got rid of they just
kind of kept him around because they
weren't really sure what to do with him
and it was always like let's keep him on
the back burner because maybe he'll
become useful at some point along one he
never really did but it was like maybe
he'll become useful at some point but
the fact remains that everybody who
basically exists in the superhero
community in or around the travelers
kind of looks at her like hey this is
awesome you know this is pretty
fantastic because we've got more super
people now one thing to keep in mind
here though is that humanity was kind of
on its way to finally beginning to trust
Superman and so I guess the new 52
Superman that was kind of a big deal you
know when Dan Jergens wrote Superman
Lois Lee Clark and it was the return of
the pre new 52 Superman he was walking
around metropolis with the pre new 52
Lois Lane and was like this is not like
our metropolis this is totally different
and keep in mind it is you know the new
52 universe is is a Earth's zero or if
I'm whatever you want to call it the pre
new 52 universe is earth one so I mean
it's like this whole crazy situation in
terms of field them crossing over to
different realities and so on and so
forth but the idea is that all of this
is basically being witnessed by Lana
Lang and this was cool because remember
Lana Lang was a childhood friend of
Superman you know she was really the
first person to learn that he has
superpowers and in a lot of way she
helped to guide him through those
various superpowers you know help to
guide him through his various abilities
I'll keep in mind everybody in this
story that we're seeing here right now
these are all new
52 characters there's no pre new 52
characters here so that's something that
I wanted you guys keep in the back of
your head but another thing that we do
is we pick up with the daily start now
this is actually really really cool to
me I really like what DC's doing with
this it's not the most important thing
but it's just something that I want to
talk about so bear with me for a second
back in the early days when Superman
first showed up The Daily Star was like
the original place that he worked at
when Superman first showed up in DC
Comics it wasn't a Daily Planet it was a
Daily Star that's where he worked now
because of the fact that the Golden Age
Superman is basically on earth too
because we got the the Earth's one
Superman so on and so forth eventually
the Daily Star became the Daily Planet
but what DC did when they launched the
new 52 is they basically combined the
best of both worlds in the post-crisis
hanukkah terrace landscape The Daily
Star was just this thing it was mission
from time to time because remember there
was no multiverse and so there was no
reason for The Daily Star to exist out
there it was just the Daily Planet and
so The Daily Star was kind of mentioned
but that was really about it it was only
done in passing with the new 52 DC just
kind of rallied it all together and what
they did is they said well in the
beginning of his career
Superman worked at The Daily Star and
then eventually went to go work at the
Daily Planet the true they were
basically competing newspapers but it's
just kind of cool to see that that
history of Superman being folded into a
new landscape with superwoman but the
fact remains here that this also
coincides with the existence of the new
52 Lex Luthor we've talked about this
before and we'll talk about it again
because remember you know every video is
somebody's first video historically
speaking Lex Luthor had always been a
bad guy in DC Comics he was always a bad
guy he was always the arch-nemesis of
Superman Superman was smart you know
Superman was intelligent but Superman's
big claim to fame was flight super
strength super speed that kind of thing
Lex Luthor was designed to be somebody
that could challenge him mentally you
know they didn't really have any powers
to speak up he had technology that would
give him abilities but Luthor himself
didn't actually have any powers the
coolest thing about the nucleus hue is
that DC began the process of revamping
his character they said hey here is the
new Lex Luthor yes he's a bad guy and he
stayed a bad guy until forever evil when
the crime syndicate from Earth 3 the
evil Justice League showed up they tried
to conquer earth they ran of all these
different teams and the result was that
Lex Luthor had to basically form his own
Justice League composed of villains in
order to defeat the crime syndicate of
America and it was beautifully written
because now it was DC going forward
saying you know as far as Lex Luthor was
concerned hey the grass
is a little greener on the other side
you know it's not bad being a good guy
like it feels kind of good and so the
result was that he went to this whole
process of redemption and it was really
cool to see him so by the time DC
rebirth kicked off
Lex Luthor's character had progressed to
the point that he's a legitimate good
guy and when the new 52 Superman died
Lex Luthor said somebody had to keep the
mantle going and so he just took on the
form of a Superman using technology now
course this was before Lex Luthor knew
that the pre new 52 suit man was already
here and of course again we'll get into
that with Superman Lois and Clark but
what licensors doing is of course
basically you know creating this massive
ship you know and it's just going to be
designed for really for a safety purpose
in the sense that it's designed to help
protect you know the various areas
around metropolis and it's supposed to
be really the first in a new line of of
weaponry that's really going to serve
the purpose of being more Defense as
opposed to often the funny thing is that
it's getting mixed reactions a lot of
people are looking at Lex Luthor and
saying hey look I remember him being a
bad guy you said you changed his ways
he's done a few good things but maybe
he's just playing the long con maybe
he's just trying to trick us and so
people are like when he comes along all
of a sudden he's got this massive
warship well it's just the first step in
a grandiose plan to basically take over
the country or something crazy like that
but in the entire situation is also
being reported on or I guess being being
observed by Lois Lane this is kind of
the crazy thing here because a lot of
you guys probably noticed so a lot of
guys probably had a lot of questions
when it came to the new 52 Lois Lane was
a character who wasn't changed all that
radically I mean she was a lot more
aggressive than she was during the whole
pre new 52 era but in terms of her being
like a hardcore reporter doing whatever
it needs or whatever she needs to do to
get the story that part of her character
was still very much intact now the whole
romance is Clark Kent that was out the
window it was Superman and Wonder Woman
was the direction they were going in but
it's time progressed DC began to move
towards the direction again a Superman
truth and basically have Lois Lane dump
his identity to the world and so for
those of you guys who picked up with DC
rebirth one thing that you may have
noticed was the new 52 Lois Lane was
gone I mean she just disappeared if
Superman died and she was out and no one
knew where she went to all we had was
the pre new 52 Lois Lane so it's like
what what happened to the new 52 Lois
Lane this is it she basically became
superwoman now the question is how did
that happen the question is how did she
become superwoman well fortunately for
us Phil Jimenez does not leave us
hanging on this answer where somebody
basically uses this ship or activates
the ship or does
and intends to send a crashing into the
city of Metropolis of course we have a
Lois Lane step in a superwoman but as
she speaks to lon
and says I need you on this like I need
your help with this well this is what we
find out this is what we learn had
basically happened this is essentially
the origin of Kenan Khan - when it went
here with a new Chinese Superman that
when the new 52 Superman died it as
energy just kind of spreads throughout
everybody else this was really covered
in like the deaths of Superman or the
death of the new 52 Superman but a lot
of people were jumping on a DC rebirth
and so this made sense to kind of come
back and basically rehash this but the
idea was that when the new 52 Superman
died his energies spread out to several
people some of them went to Lois Lane
some of them went to Lana Lang and then
some of them went to Kenan Khan the new
Chinese Superman which is actually kind
of a cool thing it was a way to
basically introduce a new character to
the DC landscape but for for Lois Lane
because of the fact that Lana had really
helped Superman learn a lot about
disabilities explore his powers learn
how to use them effectively that she was
basically able to train Lois Lane in
much the same way and this is when we
learned that there are two super women
that there's Lana Lang and there's Lois
Lane and it's really cool to see this
because if you guys notice and I'm
really hoping a lot of the guys who were
older Superman older shooting man fans
are picking this up we're getting what
amounts to electric blue and electric
red Superman now it's not identical I
mean Lois Lane is not electric blue
Superman to a degree she's just wearing
the blue Superman uniform but Lana Lang
is very reminiscent of a lecture Dredd
Superman and so it kind of creates this
really cool situation in terms of how
they function and how they relate to one
another but even then nobody else seemed
to notice they looked at the idea and
thought that you know hey we have a new
superwoman here no one knew there was a
second one and even Lex Luthor himself
was like that
that's not possible now of course as we
would expect the two of them are
basically able to stop this vessel from
crashing into a bridge bringing the
whole thing down and resulting in a
multitude or I guess a whole loss of a
whole series of lives being lost but
what we also find out is that Lois Lane
herself seems to be succumbing to the
very powers of Superman in the sense
best Superman physiology is inherently
Kryptonian the result is that it seems
as though as powers bonding with Lois
Lane are resulting in her death now this
will be fleshed out a little bit later
on past this particular issue blood it's
basically jimenez saying that Lois Lane
is on a ticking time bomb you know she's
I guess she's on a ticking clock this
me a matter of time before she basically
goes but so what happens is both Lois
Lane and Lana Lang actually travel
inside the ship figure out what's going
on who it was that turn the ship around
or what have you
and then suddenly a person that we kind
of see little glimpses of pops out of
nowhere and essentially attacks a new 52
you Lois Lane and actually ends up
killing her in the process and this was
beautifully done because what what
jimenez tells us is that for Lana Lang
and for Lois Lane they formed a very
strong kinship that had kind of been
there to a degree but not quite where
Lana Lang was a childhood friend of
Superman knew his I guess of the new 52
Superman knew his identity ever since he
was a little kid and grew up is one of
his closest friends when Lois Lane
popped up on the scene and then dumped
his identity after the world you know
Lana Lang considered is a huge breach of
trust but they kind of forged an
alliance and forged a friendship through
the very fact that they both derived
their powers from the same person it was
kind of a honoring among their own moral
code honoring among themselves in terms
of what they stood for and the legacy
that they're intended to carry on here
and so the result is that Lana kind of
began to look at Lois Lane like a sister
of sorts and what this did is basically
result and her sister being stripped
away from her being removed but this is
also DC stemming the heard and the
reason for this is because right now in
DC rebirth the pre new 52 Superman the
pre new 52 Lois Lane they're the only
kids on the block right now they're the
only Superman and Lois Lane on the block
in terms of how we view those individual
characters now of course we have the
missing Clark Kent and that's kind of a
funny thing here is in the final moments
of her life Lois Lane realizes who the
unknown Clark Kent is at least it seems
like she understands where the very
early she seems to understand the whole
idea of powers and so on and so forth
and her relation to the new 52 Superman
but the fact remains here that the new
52 Lois Lane is dead she's gone she's
removed from the landscape and this was
really what DC seems to be going for is
the idea thinning out the herd and
making it so that we don't have like two
or three versions of Lois Lane running
around two or three versions of Superman
running around or anything like that but
it's kind of reducing those numbers that
it's a very easy and a very simple way
to follow but again this is really just
the rebirth issue at this point we don't
really know who this woman is at least
as far on the story we're not really
sure what's going on with her all we
know is that she seems to possess the
power to kill people with extraordinary
abilities in this instance she was
successfully able to kill Lois Lane
superwoman but when that being said guys
again this is really more of just kind
of an introductory
issue for the whole superwoman mythos
vici rebirth so it was really more
exposition I mean the story's pretty
easy to follow but it's much like
Deathstroke in the sense that you know
it is part of the main superwoman
rebirth vol 1 but one of the lessons
that I learned with Deathstroke is
somebody tries to do too much too fast
and so it's really easy to kind of go
and treat issue number one is the
rebirth issue and then jump into the
main story itself in order to keep
things organized structured and pretty
easy to follow but if you guys are new
here to comment explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the rob course you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all in it peace
[Music]
you